[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre rendez-vous photo
avec Claude chose bonjour bonjour
Patrice
parfois voilà on perd la mémoire
donc Claude
d'abord photographe et puis vous venez
régulièrement nous parler de l'actualité
de la photo d'exposition sur la photo et
là on va parler de deux expositions qui
vont séduites l'une et l'autre à des
titres tout à fait divers l'une qui
concerne un photographe connu et qui
s'appelle jordaniel laurieux que vous
avez rencontré qui est exposé
actuellement à Versailles à la galerie
des antiquaires et puis une autre
exposition qui n'exposition
internationale qui a lieu aux Mesnil sur
le thème de l'environnement
qui vous a passionné aussi alors on va
peut-être commencer par jean-Daniel
Lorieux d'abord racontez-nous qui
Jean-Daniel laurieux est un monsieur qui
est né en il y a déjà quelques années
mais qui est très un personnage très un
personnage très agréable très
intéressant
il est né quand même dans les années 37
ça a été quelqu'un qui a 90 ans à peu
près voilà c'est ça c'est un monsieur
qui qui était si on pouvait le comparer
avec d'autres grands photographes de
mode el Munt Newton Guy Bourdin
donc c'est c'est tous les grands
photographes de
de la de la photographie de mode alors
effectivement
Jean-Daniel il a comment il a commencé à
découvrir la photo lors de son service
militaire en Algérie et d'ailleurs vous
verrez que dans l'interview que on a
réalisé il parle de son sa rencontre
avec ce petit chat qu'il avait trouvé
moi j'ai trouvé vous voulez qu'on
commence à regarder peut-être la
première interview là il y a de deux
interviews la première vous lui demandez
comment il a rencontré au fond la photo
c'est ce que je voulais poser la
question
nous n'avions pas très envie
d'être militaire parce qu'il y avait
quand même des problèmes en Algérie donc
nous étions un peu contre cette bataille
qui après c'est appelé la guerre
d'Algérie et là-bas par hasard un jour
le colonel avait une photo ou une
affiche d'un film qui s'appelait
lénafettes sur lequel était marqué leur
lieu j'avais été dans dans ce film
j'étais pour ne pas partir pour essayer
de repousser attendre que la bataille
d'Algérie se termine nous nous étions
mis dans je m'étais mis dans le cinéma
dans la mise la mise en scène j'ai
commencé de ce fait à monter pour le 20e
bataillon de chasseurs portés où j'étais
un service photo et cinéma donc j'ai
commencé la photo malheureusement de
cette façon là quand je suis revenu
comme j'avais eu pas mal de
de morts j'avais même eu un chat dans
les bras qui a fait une balle dans la
tête à ma place et je dois dire que
c'est peut-être le ciel qui m'a envoyé
un ange gardien parce que quand il y a
eu tout à coup à une fusillade et bien
les balles sont passées par chance à
côté de moi et mon chat que j'avais
ramassé aussi dans les égouts à Oran un
petit chat mais qui vivait dans ma jeep
partout comme ça toujours est-il que
quand je suis revenu à Paris en France
puisque je suis né à Paris j'étais
évidemment assez secoué et je ne me suis
pas fait soigner parce que beaucoup de
gens quand même ont-ils besoin je crois
de psy et moi le week-end je
je m'embêtais un peu et ma mère qui
était quelqu'un de aussi souvent photos
qui chantait l'opéra etc qui était très
joyeuse elle me dit bah bien je t'emmène
à la campagne chez une amie et j'arrive
chez cet ami et cet ami dans la
conversation je l'entend dire ben tiens
mardi je dois photographier Jean Gabin
et moi je dis tiens Jean Gabin c'est un
acteur que nous venions et je dis mais
vous êtes photographe oui oui bien sûr
elle est photographe c'est Cosette alors
je dis Cosette me dit c'est mademoiselle
Harcourt vous voyez mademoiselle arco et
alors donc elle me dit mais si ça vous
amuse vous faites quoi venez demain donc
j'ai commencé la photographie au studio
à
c'est intéressant parce que voilà c'est
pour fuir d'abord les horreurs de la
guerre d'Algérie qui se met la photo et
puis après voilà une coïncidence de
quelqu'un qui me photographier Gabin
c'est intéressant c'était si tu veux
Patrice c'est j'ai été séduit par ce
moment particulier qui lui est très
intime donc raconte cette avec ce petit
chat
et si tu veux c'est un moment d'ailleurs
même la façon dont il a pas là à ce
moment-là je sais pas si tu arrives il
est très ému par ce chat il voit comme
un signe de de divinité donc du destin
qu'il a qui lui a épargné cela mais je
ferai juste une petite parenthèse je
connais aussi d'autres photographes qui
ont fait des photos de guerre comme
Gilles Caron comme comme
mccullyn dans ma Culin il a toujours
fait des photos en espérant que de
guerre qui était très dur si tu veux
c'est quand il a fait la guerre du Liban
il montrait ça en espérant que les
hommes comprennent qu'il fallait arrêter
la guerre donc je je vais revenir plus
tôt sur gendarmerie alors cette
exposition alors cette exposition se
situe dans le carré des antiquaires à
Versailles dont le passage des
antiquaires elle a été organisée par
justement une association qui gère les
antiquaires de du passage et
dans le but alors dans chaque stand de
ces antiquaires voir parfois il y a une
à deux photos de jean-Daniel Lorieux
alors c'est vrai que parfois les
photographiés parce que il y a plein de
reflets dans les vitres mais moi je
j'inciterai des gens d'aller voir quand
même ce qui était
parce que c'est c'est quand même pour
moi c'est quelqu'un jean-Daniel Lorieux
qui est qui est flamboyant si tu veux
toutes ces images elles sont elles ont
été prises à une époque où la publicité
se découvrir un petit peu donc tu vois
toujours avec des images c'est très
glorées donc il fallait faire de l'art
de la publicité et Jean-Daniel en parle
de façon
merveilleuse il m'a parlé des photos de
qu'il a fait aux États-Unis il avait
carrément déplacé un porte-avion quoi
pour faire sa photo de
publicités
en effet des mais il m'a dit il est
parti en avion avec voilà et puis c'est
un c'est un grand coloriste aussi tu
vois donc de la couleur du sens de
l'image de la couleur donc on voit donc
à l'écran les publicités qu'il avait
fait pour Chanel et ça reste quand même
quelque chose de surprenant moi j'avoue
que ça m'a surpris de voir ça c'est
quelque chose qui est très très
intéressant comme voilà
donc oui c'était à la fois alors oui
voilà tu vois c'est cette photo idée il
avait déplacé un hélicoptère et un
porte-avion moi je sais pas comment tu
peux déplacer un porte-avion mais bon et
ça veut dire qu'il y avait des moyens
qui étaient extrêmes et oui c'est un
grand photographe au fond oui de mode on
pourrait dire
de la publicité de publicité mode donc
mais c'est quelqu'un qui avait son
regard il travaillait avec des
assistants il y a une photo d'ailleurs
qui invite les gens à venir à cette
exposition où il est assis dans un
fauteuil des pieds dans l'eau et puis
derrière son assiette Blade et il
regarde que le trouver le bon moment
pour appuyer c'est c'est ce sont des
principes généraux qu'on peut appliquer
dans la photographie
ce que je veux dire si tu veux c'est que
à un moment tu fais quand tu fais une
photo c'est c'est toi qui parle c'est ce
que tu ressens devant un lieu un
personnage quoi que tu veuilles pour
dire je fais j'appuie et parce que ça me
n'oublions pas que la photo cet
événement que tu as que tu as
photographié ne pourra plus se
reproduire absolument puisque le temps
passe
il y a plus c'était pas ce qui était
vrai avant c'est pas ce qui serait vrai
après et j'ai appris aussi que
Jean-Daniel est un peintre alors il a
fait de la peinture
qu'on peut voir
et dans laquelle demander quoi
il parle un peu de ces expériences
diverses et variées dont je lui ai posé
une question à un moment je lui dis mais
monsieur je connaissais Lucien Clerc je
l'avais rencontré et Lucien Clerc disait
pour bien photographier une femme il
faut l'aimer ou la voir aimer et on a
parlé de ça et tu verras la réponse
qu'il en fait
moi mon but finalement étant donné que
j'avais eu la chance de revenir ce qui
n'a pas été le cas tout le monde
malheureusement de ce service militaire
et bien j'ai passé mon temps à je venais
une semaine à Paris et trois semaines en
voyage et j'ai eu la chance d'être dans
des magazines merveilleux à Vogue où
tout le monde était joyeux bonne humeur
dans la vie la chose importante c'est de
montrer que le ciel est bleu que le
soleil est là et que les femmes sont
belles parce que la femme c'est aussi
quand même la race forte il y a quand
même pas mal de personnes qui pensent
que de mettre une jolie femme sur la
plage au soleil c'est facile en réalité
vous savez même pour faire la photo la
couverture de Dior il y a un grand
chapeau
il faut quand même trois quatre heures
pour que tout soit bien maintenant si
vous voulez tout est différent parce
qu'on retouche on remet le ciel bleu on
refait tout mais à l'époque évidemment
les photos c'était la diapo et
pratiquement aucune de ces photos n'est
retouchée je pense une chose si vous
voulez si vous avez envie d'être
photographe ou de faire de belles photos
je crois qu'il faut toujours
avoir l'ambition
d'admirer quelques personnes que vous
soyez musicien chanteur ou autre chose
je crois que d'admirer différentes
personnes et bien tout à coup vous êtes
un peu dans leur lignée et
éventuellement ça devient vous voilà
c'est ça la vie c'est ça
parce que justement il admiration peut
avoir l'admiration le sens le sens du
plaisir de la vie c'est très important
chez lui et puis alors si on revient
plus précisément à ce que la
photographie ce qu'il dit lui
c'est vrai que c'est une époque où on
pouvait pas toucher c'est vrai la photo
donc donc il y avait un temps beaucoup
plus long de préparation je suppose de
voilà d'installation de d'attendre le
bon moment où le soleil est là etc c'est
c'est surtout si tu veux que un moment
le modèle comme on dit comme il dit un
peu plus loin dans l'autre partie le
modèle va rentrer en communication avec
le photographe c'est à dire qu'il va y
avoir un échange qui est très bref quand
tu fais du studio du portrait donc un
moment il y a le modèle tu lui dis je
veux ça et un moment le modèle
professionnel surtout il va il va te
regarder et il va te donner ce que tu
attends mais c'est un moment qui est
très bref il faut savoir le saisir et ça
c'est extrêmement difficile très bien le
faire
comme quelques quelques autres de ses
confrères qui sont des grands grands
photographes
de mode qui sont des grands photographes
tout à l'heure j'ai pas cité mais tu as
un type genre huissier
donc était entendu il a travaillé il
parle aussi du Studio Harcourt il a fait
c'est un peu c'est c'est donc
et donc je
connais pierre Anthony Allard qui a été
directeur artistique du Sud qui te dit
la même chose
BIM
ne voulait travailler qu'avec la lumière
continue parce que pour midi c'est la
lumière du cinéma et donc quand tu je
fais et tu installes de ta lumière et tu
vois tout de suite le résultat alors que
avec quand tu travailles avec des flashs
tu sais pas ce que ça va donner alors le
Studio Harcourt il faut il faut dire que
c'était très très noir et blanc c'est ça
c'est très très comment te dire très
travaillé enfin
c'est de à peu près toutes les photos
sont sur la même forme d'une façon
générale quoi oui oui c'est les photos
assez exceptionnelles et cet ami Pierre
Antony Allard il peut en parler c'est un
vrai égal quand tu l'entends parler de
ça alors donc
Jean-Daniel Lorius c'est jusqu'au 30
juillet avec ça dans la galerie des
outils voilà vous avez plusieurs photos
dans plusieurs types le passage là où il
y a de l'historique
cette petite cour où tu as tu peux
admirer un certain nombre de photos
alors ça c'est une photo très
particulière qui a été faite dans la la
comment s'appelle le ministère de la
marine de Louis XV qui aujourd'hui la
bibliothèque principale de Versailles
donc c'est la cour des c'est le je sais
plus comment s'appelle mais c'est au
premier étage c'est un lieu qu'il faut
visiter parce que c'est c'est quand même
un lieu qui est superbe on fait un écart
sur l'historique de Versailles alors on
va partir pour les minutes oui où il y a
une exposition internationale sur le
thème où il écologie de l'envirgies
voilà c'est ça et qui vous a c'est
d'excusé vous avez beaucoup aimé oui
j'ai beaucoup aimé parce que donc cette
photographie
qui a monté cette cette exposition se
prénomme claire Pathé c'est une personne
qui avait fondé le
cette exposition qui avait à Paris
s'appelait circulation au 104 donc c'est
dans et donc elle elle fait vraiment une
exposition internationale où elle a dans
plusieurs pays où elle est passée elle a
fait des photos pour montrer comment les
gens se comportent et c'est quelque
chose dans un lieu qui
[Musique]
les photos qu'on voit sur les roses les
réseaux sociaux je dirais que ce sont
des photos
comment pourrais-je dire pour pas être
de les gens on appuie on partage le
moment de l'émotion devant quelque chose
là tu vois les photos qu'on voit à
l'écran c'est des photos qui ont été
faites en Asie d'accord et j'ai mis des
photos comme ça sur ma page facebook et
j'ai des ribambelles de gens des
asiatiques qui viennent les liker quoi
mais c'est pas ça l'intérêt moi ce que
je me montrais c'est que c'est la
diversité la diversité le les gens il y
a la réflexion aussi le partage d'un
moment avec un lieu où des personnages
et c'est ça qui est intéressant et
diversité donc dans l'approche
photographique et peut-être
dans la composition unicité dans le dans
les préoccupations parce qu'il y a une
préoccupation écologique et tu sais que
je vais pas je vais le je l'ai déjà
rappelé mais photographie veut dire
écrire avec la lumière il y en a qui
écrivent avec des mots et les
photographes ils le font avec la lumière
donc
[Musique]
une émission justement sur ce que
je te remercie pour merci beaucoup
Daniel Lorieux galerie des antiquaires à
Versailles jusqu'au 30 juin juillet
pardon et exposition internationale de
photos minus et ça c'est jusqu'à la fin
du mois de juin merci beaucoup de dire
mais il faut se dépêcher c'est cartés à
Versailles c'est la fin là 18 18
[Musique]